after a 19-hour search Commander Lee and
his crew had almost given up
hope they'd lost track of a boat
carrying migrants heading to
Spain but on their way back to Port the
radar detects
something there it is a light shining in
the distance the captain believes around
150 people are on
board it's very risky and complicated
especially at night when now in the
middle of an ocean storm we're close to
the vessel it can be dangerous for them
and for us we have to be careful in our
intervention not to capsize their
boat in rough Seas four Navy Commandos
prepared to board the wooden fishing
vessel their mission to bring all the
passengers onto the Navy ship using
Force if necessary Africans stopping
African migrants to protect another
continent's borders a mission on African
waters for the European Union funded by
Europeans the migrants are not in
Europe's territorial Waters they have
not broken any laws but for sagal's Navy
this is a rescue operation women and
children many show signs of hunger and
dehydration Jamila Barry says their
Journey began in The Gambia they were
halfway to Europe I feel very
disappointing and uh heartbroken I can
say because it wasn't my aim to be gu by
the Navy as we sail back to Port anger
turns to anguish and shame the group
Falls silent each thinking of the $1,000
gone to waste this isn't how they hoped
the journey would end they're now going
to have to return home empty anded to
the life they had left behind at D the
wallow docks sagales Security Forces
take the migrants including jamaa into
custody I AED my life to Greater and
better than this who will help of the
family we Tak me to take so many risks
cuz this is the second time Tak the
journey
so it's not
easy it is mission accomplished for
Spanish and senales forces keeping
Europe safe and free from Africans in
search for a better
life Nicholas Hawk Al jazer D car